[Music]
steve uh we're all so happy for you
you're such a talented nice person
you've had so much success but i think
it's good to explore with with people
that have done so well uh and let young
people know that what didn't always go
this well for you you struggled a little
bit you had some you had some crappy
jobs i did again happy jobs yeah one of
my first jobs i worked in the produce
department of a supermarket and i would
one of my jobs was to wrap fruit in
plastic wrap
and uh and i was bad i was pretty much i
was bad at at every aspect of the job it
was not it doesn't seem i mean i'm not
trying to be salty it doesn't sound like
it'd be that hard what was what was the
problem well you there was a hot plate
and it would it would melt the
underneath the wrap it would melt the
plastic but i would put my hands on it
and melt my hands like i'd burn my hands
and i had to also stock stock the
shelves and we in the produce section we
stocked popcorn among other things and
i one day i poked a hole in in the bag
of popcorn
and the popcorn spilled out and i became
jerry lewis oh
there's the popcorn how do i stop the
pop
it's a 900 pound bag of popcorn yeah to
me it seemed that way so i took one of
those at that point you had the guns
that put the uh you know the price tag
on it and the stickers so i i fixed it
with about 18 little price tags
and then my manager came by about an
hour later to check my work oh what's
this and he pulled the sticker away and
popcorn coming all over oh mr davis i
didn't know
what i was i didn't know it's jerry
lewis oh wow jerry you uh you were you a
telemarketer for a while i sold i sold
wine uh by phone how do you sell wine
over the phone exactly
um you can't do it and you had all of
you know you have your cards the
varietal characteristics of this you say
things like oaky yeah a lot but when
it's buttery exactly when in doubt say
well it has a
it has a buttery sort of
afterbirth
what
what what did you say you're a terrible
telemarketer
it was one day
it was one day of my life you know uh
people say this about you all the time
you get this and i think it's a
double-edged sword or i'm guessing it is
that
steve probably such a nice guy such a
nice guy such a normal nice guy and
those are a lot of the characters that
you play and i would think at some point
does that ever get do you ever
fantasize about are people like sean
penn or jack nicholson who are known for
being abrasive and so i've actually seen
those guys be kind of
brushed with people and people love it
they can tell someone to f off and the
person's like wow wow i got
he really zinged me he really got me and
they love it but you you always have to
be nice it's interesting because i just
did a bunch of press for this movie with
meryl streep and tommy lee jones and
tommy lee jones is a guy who does not
suffer fools he is yeah you know he's a
pretty tough guy and to watch him with
the press is amazing because they're
like uh mr joe they're so afraid of him
right and he's got them right where he
wants them well me on the other hand if
they don't there's no respect
that is not true there's a ton of
respect but it's just that thing where
if if you ever cracked for a minute and
got slightly irritated with someone hey
that's a thing i don't really think i'm
that nice i think i'm probably just a
sociopath who understands that niceness
sells
i'm just saying there's no one behind
that mask who knows